hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the don't laugh
challenge we got right back here but we
also got away there's a special guest
and we are going to be trying to make
him laugh
this time what's different is that we
have an entire ensemble of props we'll
get an insert shot of that later here so
those props we can use any one of them
in any way we feel he's getting the
water all mixed in with a saliva and
that's really more very moist and we're
going to try to get him to laugh using
whatever we have the tools available now
the rule guard we can't touch him we
can't caress him we can't poke at him we
can't do anything to him except taunt
him with the tools that we have yeah
ready mmm okay cool started I'm just
going to stand here and kind of look at
you hear from holy I'm pretty sure it's
not a dildo it's a doctor services 90
seconds what what the Apple you guys
didn't even go and help them oh yeah oh
yeah I know you had the trouble hard I
what were you doing if you guys were
helping on this one literally there's
probably 30 seconds like waste like it
was supposed to be healthy oh boy Saul
drivel I am a loser I'm a popular
internet meme I'm known around as grumpy
cat hi I am real
[Music]
17100 that's make Hulk angry hope drunk
with heat hang on hey man I don't know
why because you look like my like my
Mutant X on it 3 2 1
beginning it's me Mario
[Music]
I felt the vibe really freaky why go in
one on the swing Devon hey you want to
make a sketch comedy Whitney hey let's
go running through the woods Mon it's a
me Mario hey look it's a Mario yeah
it's me Mario hey we didn't look it's me
back when you had hair remember those
days wasn't that fun times
he's impenetrable to go god damn it I
scream spit up I want to break you in
the first 10 seconds right okay you have
some plan I just know it's no I'm going
to not fair because you guys cheated on
me what I've never gel like with water
Godfather let me tell you something the
wrong Rock virus that so funny I use on
your brain just something so dope just
[Laughter]
three two one
starting it's a clue it's me top of the
morning to you wait makes himself laugh
that's your problem
I was bullied in high school what okay
that's the quiz represent me no no like
I was bullied I was here to be in high
school
three two one
we're going oh
[Music]
that's good juice he's on his a game
this round easy it's okay I'm sure God
to notice notice what he's been doing
everything he's been doing makes himself
laugh okay he's got to give him a taste
of his own medicine
okay that's going to be the secret okay
here we go start bonnet laughs now you
see the cows reproductive cycle you take
the bull penis and they show so the cow
hump and then when you when you get it's
tickly in there you go there you go now
watch closely as ejaculation starts ah
Vic stupid Evy and hit squeak the first
week I decided to work a little lovely
baby I'm right I was bullied in high
school
[Music]
damn it I've been impaled it's a one
from the movie don't you remember you
didn't see frozen fog across DMX you you
help
[Music]
like holding it in with your hands
everyone has done that I cannot man I
want one more try
I want one after one more we've all lost
belief right yeah okay were you ready to
start it yeah can hope tick bag sir hey
Hulk would you like turndown service
turn down for what this is too fun so
thank you everybody for watching thank
you guys for joining us here if you guys
enjoyed us let us know in the comments
below if you want to see another don't
laugh challenge will get another guest
in here we'll have a lot of fun with it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out their channels is
problems Lord meaning 777 I mean marklar
see you next time bye
[Music]